now i've been talking this morning about
long covid which is
all a bit of a mystery people seem to
have different symptoms and
no one can quite get to the bottom of it
one person who
is really suffering is children's author
michael rosen who can join us now it's
good to see you
this morning and i know you you actually
had a really rough time with covid
didn't you actually in the
in the initial stages
yes that's right i was in intensive care
for a 47-48 days i was in a coma for
about 40 of those um so it hit me really
badly yes
and so coming out of that now when
hopefully people think well maybe you
you'd find some sense of recovery again
this long
covered issue has really affected you
what sort of symptoms are you showing
with that
well because i got micro bleeds in my
brain it knocked out my
left eye and left ear and
it seems as if the covid virus can
attack what are called the peripheral
nervous system the edges of ourselves if
you like
so i've got numb toes and i get
dizziness quite often the blood clots
which are also caused by covid have
cleared up it seems in my brain
and in my lungs um and then there's a
general fatigue because
it's thought that the virus now one of
the thoughts every cell has got a little
thing that they call the powerhouse of
the cell the mitochondrion
and they think it probably somehow
rather attacks that that's the little
bit in your cell
that turns the food into energy so that
seems to be
one of the reasons why there's so many
symptoms so
where has this left you in terms of of
trying to get on with life
well i've adapting to the fact that i
can hardly see so i can't really see you
looking at my screen there
this year i have a hearing aid which
sort of gives me a bit of 3d
sound but it's it's quite strange it
sounds as if i'm always listening to the
radio
which as it happens i do radio so it's
kind of rather odd
it sounds as if i'm on the radio to
myself all the time
and the the numb toes are more of an
irritant than
a sort of you know a disability or
anything like that but it is
kind of annoying um particularly if i'm
walking around in slippers and so on uh
because it just
it it sort of bothers me but it's the
dizziness that
surprises me because sometimes um
my wife emma she sort of notices i kind
of stagger against the wall or suddenly
grab the table
so that's a bit worrying if i'm out what
has happened in terms of i mean in
getting a diagnosis for this and and
the potential for any sort of treatment
because
i mean with all this we know people are
presenting different
perhaps similar but still different uh
uh responses to lancovid i mean it's
it does seem that getting any sort of of
actual
treatment is is extremely difficult
well i think we're coming into the
category of what people call post-viral
syndrome so that it's known that viruses
of various kinds
um can have two four five ten
twenty years effect people talk about me
obviously and it's it's not imaginary so
you know people are saying well some of
it we just have to live with people
um who are suffering severe severe
fatigue also
other people are suffering what they're
calling brain fog
i think i did get that in the first
months after i came out of intensive
care
i was getting memory loss and and
getting muddled and fuzzy if there was
as it were too much information coming
at me
there are now some long covered clinics
um i suspect there are some people i
well i belong to a long coveyed
group on facebook uh other social medias
are available
um that um we join and we share some of
these and i can see some people in
severe difficulty about literally
getting up
some days they can some days they can't
i call it alternate day syndrome i sort
of
if i over exercise one day and i do try
to exercise a bit every day
then i kind of i get a kind of bout of
of being able to do virtually nothing
for a few hours the next day
what is your message then i mean
obviously some people are
are trying to get treatment and there is
taught now that these long covered
clinics gonna have to be around for a
lot longer than
what was initially planned um but is
there a sense i mean with the facebook
groups and all the rest of it
is there a sense that just being able to
connect with people who are
suffering in a similar way does does
that help is there a sense of community
and mutual support there
there is i mean when i put up the fact
that i was getting these bouts of
dizziness
up came another whole set of posts of
people saying oh me too
me too and then again i posted up some
of the latest stuff that seems to be
pointing at the the mitochondrion that
somewhere other the virus is getting
into the mitochondria
um and again the huge great wave of post
some people
are putting up what they find useful you
know vitamins or
other things and the moment that people
are experimenting with that
and the attitude to exercise is little
and often rather
than trying to do kind of great big
bouts of exercise for
you know a couple of hours one day and
doing nothing for a few days
but doing little and often and i find
that a a useful recommendation
but where there are things like severe
skin rashes and so on i get
mild skin rash um
then you know the gp and some medication
is
is necessary but the fatigue
you know there's not much you can do
about it but it's actually people
younger than me who are trying to get
into work five days a week
i mean some of it's being if you like
disguised because of
um lockdowns and so on and people
working from home
but there are a lot of people out there
who couldn't
uh if there was full ordinary working
conditions wouldn't be able to work for
five days a week it's just you know 40
hours it's too much
well look we really appreciate you
sharing your experiences with us
michael good to see you as always thank
you